given the following and it may have two
different things aside simpler isn't it
slightly okay give it the following
coordinates of points that's what these
guys are okay and equations of lines
that's what these guys are plot and
graph them neatly on the set of axes
below lamely each key one grid like one
of these this is one grid square equals
one unit
okay so we'll start with an easy bit
which most of you guys saw did pretty
well we'll plot the points right the
only the hardest thing to remember is
you've got an x and a y every single
time and it's alphabetical
right XY XY so 2 3 if I count one grid
square that's going to be one two that's
so that's where I'm going to be for an X
and one two three that's what I'm gonna
be for the Y they line up there so
that's where a is so you can have a look
at where yours is right now that's a B
is one negative one so you're gonna go
to the right one and down one that's the
negative one there so that's where B is
and our last point negative 4 4 sorry
negative 4 negative 4 I should say so
you go 4 to the left this way and you go
for down so that's where C should be
okay so there you go that's a B and C
let's have a look at D I'll do this some
I'll do these a couple of different ways
so y equals x plus 1 first we'll do the
triangle method do you remember this
what we need to do is look at this guy
right y equals x plus 1 and to do the
triangle map that you need two things
you need the y-intercept and then you
need to know the gradient which is gonna
fit a triangle in there okay so what's
the y-intercept of this rule or this
equation
what's the one why does it's a
particular number it's this guy on the
end it's the plus one so I know that
these slide passes through here that's
that's plus 1 now I need the gradient as
well where do I read the gradient from
here
it's hiding it's a bit sneaky it's the
number in front of the X you're like
there isn't a numbered one of the X
which means it's one that's exactly
right
so the gradients one that means you go
across one and up one that's the run and
that's the rise okay so I'm gonna go
through here so now I get my ruler out
I've got to go through these points I'm
trying to do this as neatly as I can
something like this here they go
so they do say label each clearly so I
should say well this line I've just
drawn is y equals x plus one okay all
right let's do this one y equals
negative 2x minus 1 the other way you
could do this the other easy way is
using x and y intercepts x and
y-intercepts so there's a y-intercept
right there negative 1 so that means I
get to go through here now how do I get
the x-intercept again do you better do
that the to that negative 2 that will
give you the gradient so I could use
that to graph that'll be fine now the
other way to do it is to say well if I
want the what did I ask for whoever I
want to be x intercept the x-intercept
I'll say let y equal to 0 I wonder if
that jogs your memory at all okay so I
put that into this equation to get 0
equals negative 2x minus 1 let's see how
can I rearrange this I'll put the 2x
over here and then what do I do
I want to say x equals something right
so I've got a / - yes so I get negative
a ha
okay so here's my y-intercept he would
be my x-intercept negative 1/2 cuz
there's zero and there's negative 1 6
halfway so now I join them up okay let
me
do this I'll try yeah just just until Oh
hold on I just making sure this is oh
yeah actually there you go okay so this
is y equals negative 2x minus 1 now by
the way before I think was Jack said you
know that negative 2 at the front what's
that gonna be that's the gradient right
you can see what that means is it's a
steep excuse me oh excuse me it's a
steep line going down okay so that's why
you've got that [ __ ] check the front we
didn't use it but you can last one 1/2 X
minus 3 I'm gonna do that the same way I
did before so you've got that negative 3
down there that's mine that's my
y-intercept and I've got the gradient of
1/2 so that means every time I go across
2 units I've got one so I say that's a
too small let's try this
how's that Wow look at my enormous
stubby fingers okay I try not to think
about it okay here we go
there we go that is y equals trust me
after you've looked at yourself on your
hundreds of hours you stop think you
matter okay there there's your three
points one two three and then these
three lights you got the picture
so yours should roughly look like that
okay I'll give you a a warning you'll
get us to draw graphs like this if they
provide for you a set of axes like I
have and a grid like I have they expect
you to be super accurate right they
expect the gradient of negative two to
look like negative two and to be able to
tell that different from QC this one's
got a gradient of one this one's got a
gradient of a half they look different
they're not parallel so you'll be
expected to do that okay